somebody's watching and saying mike
you've inspired me man i'm gonna go
uh uh uh either buy or i'm gonna go be a
designer it's like
that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna set
it up what would you tell the creative
kind of like you
if you could give any feedback to the
creative who's like you if i would have
done three of those per year 66 000
i'm fine with the lifestyle that i have
that would have been great not 69
million
what do you what feedback you got for
the creatives and what feedback you have
for those that are saying
i'm not fully comfortable with
blockchain i am sitting on a million
dollars i wouldn't mind investing in a
little bit of the blockchain
nfts that's coming out what do you
suggest me doing give me feedback to
both the creative
and the investor to the creative i would
say start in every days and i and there
have been
literally you know sort of tens of
thousands of people who have started
every day
because of like me seeing me do this and
some of those people have
hundreds of thousands of followers in
their own right so this is very much
like a movement in
you know i've been bugging people to
start every days for many many years and
a ton of them have and it's something
that is you know sort of a known sort of
movement in digital art
doing every days um so yeah i would
recommend doing that and again
i would not sort of focus on the money
piece of it the money aspect of it focus
on getting better
and uh the money will come or it might
not come
but like you can't control that piece of
it that piece of it is very hard
what you can control is how much you sit
your ass down and you like practice and
work your ass off
that you can very much control and it's
about just
putting in the work every single day
there there's no shortcut to it like
there's no
fancy oh here's you know some advice
that you never heard that somehow is
some shortcut no no
it's just the work that's all it is it's
just about load of work like there's no
other
you know way around it um to the
investor
i would say if you want to get into nfps
i would look at those crypto punks
i would also look there's this guy named
people who makes awesome artwork
no i would say i i think it's one of
those things where you really need to
sort of do your due diligence um look at
this stuff try and understand the space
more um
and sort of have it on your radar i
think it's going to get
more and more you know an alternate
asset class that i think
people are it's going to get more and
more viable i think we've sort of
you know kind of gotten used to the idea
that
you know equities have been the
predominant asset class for the last
hundred years you grow up
you get a little extra money and you
choose a corporation and you give that
money to corporations well kids hate
corporations
they super hate corporations and so this
idea that they're just gonna
automatically grow up get a couple extra
bucks and you know give it to amazon
give it to google give it to blah blah
blah
i don't know that i see that just
automatically continuing forever
and so if there's alternate asset
classes like nfts like bitcoin something
like that i could see those being a real
sort of
you know alternative that people would
like to sort of like well i'd rather buy
a people than i would
you know put it into berkshire hathaway
so
i think it's one of these things that
you know could be
really important growing up because the
other part of it is you have much more
of a sense of digital ownership of these
and you can sort of you know do them and
trade them and sort of
own them with with much less rules and
much less oversight again you go back to
stocks
you have to trade in a certain time a
certain way
certain places you know there's a lot of
rules around it and those rules
like we saw with gamestop those rules
can change on a dime
and it's like oh here's the new rules
don't like it go yourself
this is the new rules kids didn't like
that nobody liked that
and so if you have something like this
that has less rules and it's
you have more of a sense of ownership
which again people are yearning for that
online you go to
you know you give your data to facebook
and google you stop owning it they own
it then
you've given it to them and so this is
another thing where you have much more
of a sense of ownership which is not
something we're used to online we're
used to giving people stuff and then
they own it they do whatever the hell
they want with it
that's not what this is and so this is
where i think it could be
you know a massive massive alternate
asset class moving forward so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye